España es conocido por ser el país de Julio
Iglesias, del flamenco y de las altas de desempleo.
Incluso ahora, cuando toda Europa está saliendo
de la crisis, este país mantiene un paro
superior al de Iraq o Albania.
En otras palabras, que España no es, precisamente,
un modelo en lo que a economía se refiere.
Sin embargo, hay una región que se sale de
este patrón.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, hablamos del
País Vasco, también conocido como Euskadi.
Junto con Navarra, son las dos regiones más
ricas y prósperas de todo el país.
En casi todos los indicadores, tanto el País
Vasco como Navarra suelen estar en la parte
de arriba.
Muy por encima, por cierto, de Cataluña.
Dicho de otra forma, podríamos decir que
estas dos regiones son algo así como una
pequeña Alemania dentro de España, con un
sistema político totalmente distinto al del
resto del país y un tejido empresarial más
propio del Norte del Europa que del Sur.
Es más, en esta zona también existe una
lengua propia, el EUSKERA.
A diferencia del catalán, el euskera no se
parece en nada al castellano.
De hecho, los lingüistas no son capaces de
ponerse de acuerdo sobre el origen de esta lengua.
Pero si alguno de los que nos veis desde Latinoamérica
se apellida IÑARRITU o ETXEBARRÍA, podéis
decir que tenéis algún ancestro que viene
de esta región.
¡Pero no sólo eso!
Al igual que Cataluña, el País Vasco es
una región con un importante movimiento separatista.
De hecho, 10 años antes de que los políticos
catalanes comenzaran a exigir la independencia,
el gobierno vasco también intentó convertirse
en un estado soberano.
Efectivamente, hablamos del llamado PLAN IBARRETXE.
El, por aquel entonces presidente del País
Vasco, o como se le llama oficialmente, el
LEHENDAKARI vasco, Juan José Ibarretxe, intentó
un divorcio con España que salió bastante
mal.
Pero de todo eso hablaremos en otro vídeo.
Por que la pregunta de hoy es ¿Por qué el
País Vasco y Navarra son las regiones más
ricas de España?
¿Por qué decimos que tienen un sistema político
distinto al del resto del país?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
¿UNA HERENCIA MEDIEVAL?
Mucha gente piensa que este estatus especial
que tiene el País Vasco y Navarra, el llamado
CONCIERTO o CONVENIO ECONÓMICO, viene de
la edad media pero, en realidad, no es así.
Veréis, en el año 1200, el antiguo Reino
de Navarra, lo que ahora son las provincias
de ÁLAVA, BIZCAYA, GUIPÚZKUA y la propia
NAVARRA, se unió a la corona de Castilla.
Y como condición para esta unión, el rey
castellano tuvo que reconocer los llamados
FUEROS navarros.
Es decir, que este reino mantendría un gobierno
independiente con sus propias leyes, sus propios
tribunales y sus propios impuestos.
Por ejemplo, ningún ciudadano navarro podía
estar obligado a hacer el servicio militar.
Estos fueros navarros se mantuvieron prácticamente
intactos durante siglos ¡Pero no penséis
que se trata de ninguna anomalía!
Todos los sistemas políticos feudales o absolutistas,
tanto en España como en Francia o Reino Unido,
estaban llenos de regiones con derechos y
leyes especiales.
Sin embargo, la cosa cambió en el siglo XIX.
En ese momento es cuando España se consolida
como un estado moderno.
Y decide imitar el modelo de la Francia de
Napoleón, es decir, un modelo centralista.
Eso significa que casi todas las leyes se
dictarían desde la capital y se aplicarían
de igual manera por todo el territorio.
Como os podéis imaginar, esto no les hizo
ninguna gracia a los ciudadanos navarros y
vascos.
De repente, tenían que pagar más impuestos
y prestar servicio militar obligatorio.
Eso explica que, durante el siglo XIX, España
tuviera no una, ni dos, sino tres guerras
civiles, las llamadas GUERRAS CARLISTAS, donde
los partidarios del antiguo régimen, principalmente
vascos y navarros, luchaban contra el ejército
español.
Así que en 1876, con las tropas vasco navarras
derrotadas, los foros fueron abolidos.
De repente, estas 4 provincias tenían que
seguir la ley que venía de Madrid.
Además, tenían que pagar un porcentaje de
los impuestos que recaudasen al Estado Central.
A cambio, Madrid permitió que estas regiones
conservaran un estatus fiscal especial.
Y a esta concesión es a lo que llamamos el
concierto vasco, que como veis, no nació
en la Edad Media sino que se aprobó como
contrapartida tras haber abolido los fueros.
¡Pero la cosa no termina aquí!
Décadas más tarde, en 1939, la dictadura
de Franco elimina este concierto económico,
pero sólo a las dos provincias que no le
apoyaron, Guipuzkua y Vizcaya.
Como podéis ver, se trata de una historia
bastante tortuosa, con guerras y desagravios
por ambos lados.
Estas dos provincias que habían perdido sus
condiciones fiscales especiales estaban especialmente
dolidas.
Y eso se nota hasta nuestros días, donde
un enorme porcentaje de vizcaínos y guipuzkuanos
querrían independizarse de España.
Y todo esto explica que en los años 70, los
redactores de la nueva Constitución democrática
quisieran resarcir a los vascos y navarros.
Vuelve el concierto vasco pero esta vez, en
una versión moderna.
EL CUPO VASCO
A todos los que veáis este vídeo desde España,
prestad atención porque este es uno de los
temas que más confusión genera en la política
nacional.
Veréis… un ciudadano que viva en Málaga
o en Valladolid, paga la mayor parte de sus
impuestos directamente al Gobierno central.
Por supuesto que hay algunos tributos especiales
que dependen de la ciudad o de la Comunidad
Autónoma, pero la gran mayoría van para
la Hacienda Nacional.
Después, el Estado reparte este dinero entre
los diferentes gobiernos autonómicos según
le convenga.
Esto son las llamadas “transferencias autonómicas”
que habréis oído mencionar en los periódicos.
Y, por supuesto, algunas regiones suelen salir
beneficiadas de estas transferencias y otras
salen perjudicadas.
“La teoría” y digo “la teoría” porque
esto es bastante discutible, es que las regiones
más ricas ayudan a las más pobres.
Sin embargo, tanto Navarra como el País Vasco
tienen un sistema distinto.
En este caso, los gobiernos provinciales son
quienes recaudan casi todos los impuestos.
Y fijaros bien que he dicho provinciales.
Es decir, un ciudadano que viva, por ejemplo,
en Bilbao, no tributa al Gobierno Vasco sino
a la Diputación Provincial de Vizcaya.
Y este gobierno provincial tiene autonomía
para poder hacer cosas como esta:
Bizkaia cambiará el Impuesto de Sociedades
para ganar competitividad
¿Recordáis este otro vídeo en el que os
contábamos por qué Suiza es tan rico?
Una de las razones es que, en Suiza, los diferentes
cantones pueden competir entre ellos por ofrecer
mejores condiciones fiscales.
Pues bien, algo parecido ocurre entre las
provincias vascas y navarras.
Y eso explica que la tributación en esta
región sea un poco más baja que la del resto
de España.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Entonces, estas diputaciones
provinciales no pagan nada al Estado Español?
¡Nada de eso!
Aquí es donde entra en escena el llamado
CUPO VASCO.
El cupo vasco es el porcentaje que pagan estas
regiones al Gobierno Central a cambio de los
servicios comunes de los que disfrutan por
pertenecer a España.
Por ejemplo, el ejército, las embajadas,
las carreteras.
Todo eso son cosas que se pagan desde Madrid
pero que también disfrutan los vascos.
Entonces, estos tienen que pagar una parte
del coste.
¡No sólo eso!
Si por ejemplo, España decidiera aumentar
el presupuesto en defensa, este cupo vasco
también crecería de forma proporcional.
Como os podéis imaginar, todo esto es la
teoría.
La realidad es que el cupo vasco es el resultado
de negociaciones políticas.
Pero eso es otra historia.
Lo cierto es que, a diferencia de todas las
demás comunidades autónomas, el País Vasco
y Navarra sabe exactamente cuánto dinero
paga al común y con cuanto se queda.
Y, en la mayor parte de los casos, esto es
una ventaja fantástica.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque aquí no
se queda la cosa!
En principio, podría parecer que el concierto
económico es un sistema bastante justo.
Todo queda negro sobre blanco en una negociación.
Pero lo cierto es que el sistema dista mucho
de ser perfecto.
¿Recordáis que os decía que el Estado Central
reparte el dinero que recauda entre las distintas
comunidades autónomas?
¡Pues lo cierto es que tanto Navarra como
el País Vasco también forman parte de este
reparto!
Y siendo unas regiones tan ricas, sería lógico
pensar que aportan más de lo que reciben
¿Verdad?
¡Pues nada de eso!
País Vasco recibe el doble de recursos per
cápita que Madrid, Cataluña o Andalucía
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo es esto posible?
La razón es puramente política.
Como os decía, el nacionalismo vasco es tan
importante como lo puede ser el catalán.
Y eso significa que, estas comunidades autónomas
tienen sus propios partidos políticos.
Partidos como el Partido Nacionalista Vasco,
que ostenta el gobierno de su comunidad y
que también tiene una representación en
el parlamento nacional.
Y, como ya sabéis, cada año, el Gobierno
Central tiene que aprobar los presupuestos
nacionales en el parlamento.
Para eso necesita una mayoría absoluta.
Mayoría que, en la mayor parte de los casos,
requiere el apoyo de estos partidos.
Sin embargo… sólo un necio diría que esta
es la única razón que explica la prosperidad
del País Vasco.
¡Para nada!
Hay mucho más.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA ALEMANIA DE ESPAÑA
¿Os suena una empresa que se llama ORKLI?
Pues si tenéis una cocina de gas, es muy
probable que tengáis alguno de sus productos.
Se trata del líder mundial de fabricación
de sistemas para evitar accidentes y fugas
de gas.
Y su sede está en Ordizia, un pueblo de la
provincia de Guipuzkua.
Lo mismo ocurre con JMA.
SI tenéis una puerta blindada en vuestra
casa, es probable que tanto la cerradura como
las llaves estén fabricadas por esta empresa,
que está situada en MONDRAGÓN.
Son los llamados “líderes ocultos”.
Pequeñas compañías hiper especializadas
que se han convertido en los referentes de
su nicho y que arrasan en el mercado internacional.
En este otro vídeo os contábamos que Alemania
debe parte de su riqueza a las MITTLESTANDS.
Pues bien, el modelo económico vasco es muy
similar.
Es más, si tenéis la oportunidad de viajar
en carretera por Euskadi, veréis que hay
fábricas por toda su geografía.
De hecho, la distribución de la población
está mucho más dispersa que en ningún otro
lugar de España.
Por supuesto que hay grandes ciudades, pero
la mayoría de la gente vive en pequeños
núcleos urbanos, de menos de 40.000 habitantes.
Y cada uno de estos municipios tiene su polo
empresarial que da empleo a los lugareños.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué Euskadi tiene
un tejido empresarial tan homogéneo?
Volvemos al mismo principio de antes: la descentralización.
Al tener 4 haciendas distintas, con autonomía
para recaudar impuestos y hacer inversiones,
existe muchísima más competencia fiscal
que en cualquier otra parte de España.
Eso se traduce en que las inversiones públicas
no se concentran en un lugar concreto sino
que se reparten de forma homogénea.
La inversión en 'startups' tendrá una deducción
del 30% en Gipuzkoa
En otras palabras: es cierto, tanto los vascos
como los navarros juegan con una enorme ventaja
porque reciben dinero desde el estado central.
Pero ese dinero se ha invertido de forma mucho
más eficiente que en cualquier otra región.
De hecho, no es casualidad que estas dos comunidades
sean las menos endeudadas de toda España.
Y que además, apenas hayan estado salpicadas
por los casos de corrupción que han emponzoñado
el resto del país.
Así que ahora la pregunta es ¿Creéis que
se podrían rescatar algunos elementos del
modelo vasco y navarro para otros países?
¿Sería posible aplicar el concierto vasco
a todas las demás regiones?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y antes de que os vayáis, tengo que contaros
algo muy importante.
El sábado 17 de febrero voy a participar
en el evento TEDx Malagueta, en Málaga, España.
Si vivís cerca, me encantaría poderos saludar
personalmente y por eso, tengo un descuento
del 10% para todos los suscriptores de VisualPolitik.
Sólo tenéis que entrar en la web TEDXMALAGUETA.ORG
y escribir la palabra “VISUALPOLITIK”
en el código de descuento.
Por lo que me han dicho, quedan ya muy poquitas
entradas así que no esperéis más porque
tengo muchísimas ganas de veros a todos.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal, que es completamente gratuíto
y os permitirá estar al tanto de todas nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!